good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy worst day of the
week tuesday
arguably i think second worst day of the
week so that's an optimistic spin on
things no
like
it's the worst
it's gonna be okay you wanna know why
it's gonna be okay because i'm tan yeah
no i'm happy for you i got a spray tan
yesterday my first spray tan in over a
year because i didn't get one while i
was pregnant and i hasn't been gotten
one since and it's just really changing
everything about me if you can't tone it
tan it i feel so amazing no like who who
are you and i know we always say like if
you're feeling low about yourself get a
spray tan and i've been feeling low for
a while but the spray tan wasn't the
solution because i was really just
wearing like leggings and sweatshirts so
like what's a tan face gonna do for me i
could use bronzer but now that we are
baring legs on the shoulders and arms i
i went for it and i'm thrilled i've been
telling you to get it for weeks and i'm
so glad you did thrilled to bits well
you need a good enough reason to get it
because it's like is it worth smelling
like this yeah for nothing yes i don't
know the smell is for beauty but today
i'm i'm loving it so if you're watching
on youtube your girl is tan and it's
giving me an extra pep in my step oh i'm
so glad i'm like pale and chunky so um
i'm like uh
what's the word with an r
when you like resentful rdh that and
extremely i'm resentful devastated and
heartbroken got it well you've been
looking really great on the show and
like you're usually the tan one so it's
nice for me to have a day no you look
great glowy and speaking of youtube i
actually wrote down four things i wanted
to say and i have two things i'd like to
say okay i'm sure there is a crossover a
crossover so the first thing i want to
say is just issue a correction from
yesterday i was wrong um about something
and obviously that's not shocking i just
thought i should mention the jury
members from the amber heard johnny
jebtrell were not sequestered okay so it
is entirely possible that they were
engaging in social media even though
they were told not to but like if it was
me like i probably would
two is
we um
this is for the youtubers just really
quick i am we are aware of the glitch
that's been happening on our youtube
channel for the last couple weeks we're
not doing nothing about it the comments
have turned like helpful into mean um so
this morning i got one that was like
particularly like sharp you know it
can't be that hard someone fix it okay
here you go
you fix it if you can fix it like we
will pay you for the work yes so we are
aware of it we've been talking with
youtube youtube has let us know there's
a glitch on our channel um and they're
having an extremely hard time getting it
fixed there's literally nothing we can
do about it we apologize thank you to a
lot of people who have been patient we
are aware of it we are working on it two
things one typically if you watch not in
the app if you watch on a browser it
does work not for yesterday's episode
but in general people who watch on the
browser it works not in the app two by
the end of the day it works for everyone
it's just if you watch immediately after
it uploads like the thing is not working
so we are all over it we're not just
sitting ducks ignoring you we know we
apologize we're working on it and maybe
um if anyone works at youtube like we
can get this streamlined
the third thing i wanted to say was we
had a very special announcement
yesterday on our instagram if you don't
follow us what the [ __ ] are you doing um
we have a new show so it remains totally
separate from the toast the show stays
the same nothing about tmt is changing
no there's only going to be more of us
more content so we are now partnering
with spotify live which is a brand new
app from spotify um for live audio shows
so we are doing a show it's called
breaking bread it'll be every wednesday
at 7 p.m eastern time 4 p.m pacific and
it'll kind of just be a catch-up with us
kind of like an evening toast talking
about what happened on the toast this
week what happened in pop culture we'll
be doing deer toaster segments live
we'll be trying to give advice so how it
works is basically if you want to join
live and be able to like join the
conversation right in the chat maybe get
pulled up onto the stage you have to
download the spotify live app it's
called spotify live and then you can
follow us our show is called breaking
bread um and then if you don't want to
download the app which couldn't be me
you can listen live on spotify the
regular spotify app and if you don't
catch it live you can also listen on
demand later on on the spotify app but i
highly recommend downloading the spotify
live app so you can chit chat with us
we're gonna be playing games again dear
toasters maybe we're gonna do another
round of toaster karaoke it's gonna be
fun it's gonna be every wednesday for
the next couple months and we really
hope to see you guys there yeah very
very exciting and it's a way for us to
when we do deer toasters ask questions
get more context follow-up in order to
get better advice because we were saying
a few weeks ago remember and i just we
need to tie back secret projects to like
when we were talking about them yeah
that's like my biggest pet peeve when
people are like secret project and it's
like well what was that project and what
was that we never followed up because a
while ago we were saying how tear
toasters was a little frustrating
because we can't ask follow-up questions
to the person and then we said no we
have something coming that will solve
that yeah this is that thing that way
when you ask us questions on spotify
live
we can ask you questions back and get
more context and give the best advice
possible won't change wednesday's dear
toasters everyone no won't change it
it's just another way that we can give
wonderful advice so we start this week
as in tomorrow so in preparation when
you download the spotify live app follow
breaking bread so you'll get a
notification when we go live which is 7
p.m eastern time it'll be about an hour
and it'll be just two girly girls on a
wednesday night breaking bread
breaking the bread so all the details
are on our instagram we hope to see you
guys there and then my fourth and final
point following up to that is jack skate
yes
yes please explain to everyone what
happened so yesterday we posted about
our new show we were so excited we like
spent two hours writing a caption and
there were still types and there were
still typos like many many typos but we
referred to ourselves as the iconic duo
that we i feel like we call ourselves a
lot jackson claude
and i wrote jackson claude jackson
claude will be going live jackson claude
have a new spotify show and the comments
uh lost their [ __ ] minds because they
thought it was a show with jax taylor
and claudia ashrae um which would be
good also good maybe we'll pitch that to
spotify down the road breaking jacks
right
um and i just didn't know like we
weren't calling you jacks
yeah i guess no we didn't all get the
memo maybe seeing it written out with an
x like maybe because maybe because we
say it a lot we don't like write it do
we say it a lot i don't know because i
don't refer to myself but we refer to
each other as jackson quad like it's
iconic jackson claude yeah
i guess it was you know
it was lost it's a little niche i guess
so now you know
call us jackson claude but i really just
did want to clarify one
i know that the jurors were sequestered
and two no the show was not with jax
taylor today is the other sorry to
disappoint anybody yeah who was excited
about that now my first point was
breaking bread as well okay on the
second page
the same page my second point is some
exciting personal news of what i'll be
doing this weekend so i am headed to
dallas oh right and i will be at specs
dallas doing a spritz meet and greet on
saturday so here are the details that
you need to know and of course if you go
to the spritzes link in bio there's
extra details but you can get tickets
available through the link in their bio
through the end of the week and with
those pre-sale tickets you'll get
limited edition spritz merch and a tote
bag so it is saturday in dallas in the
afternoon get all the details when you
get your ticket at checkout at spritz
you have to put in the dallas zip code
in order to be eligible when you're
checking out of your order but again
head to at spritz on instagram click the
link in their bio and all of the
information is there i'm so excited to
do my first i know it's crazy you've
never done one i've never done a sports
m g and i've never done an m g by myself
i'm like oh by yourself
no it's i'd have to give you like a prep
talk before it's a lot of work you got
to keep the conversation flowing yeah no
no i don't expect it to not be a lot of
work but it's just like everybody's
coming for me no i know it's like try
like when you walk through the store and
like people start cheering like try not
to become a monster like i have a hard
time with that like i walk through the
store and i'm just like a girl walking
through a liquor store and people are
like oh my god and i'm like furry
but like you also do mg's for all of
your shows right you're an m g queen i
am now
i am new to the m g game and so it's
just like for me i'm shy welcome to the
m g community yeah i'm really excited to
meet the dallas toasters though oh
they're another level like you're gonna
love them they're it's one of our better
better communities honestly i've
actually met a lot through the years
like here and there and i'm just excited
to have it be all at together at once
under the spritz umbrella we'll be
spritzing we'll be chatting we'll be
meeting we'll be greeting wow i can't
wait for the greeting that's gonna be
huge and the meeting of course don't
forget the meeting don't forget it
anyways head over to the spritz
instagram link in bio to get your
pre-sale tickets so that you can meet
your girl and we can have a great time
i'm so excited for you that's going to
be so fun um and congrats on your first
mmg thanks so low emma j solo yeah um if
you're watching on youtube i have had
something stuck in my eyes since i woke
up this morning and it's probably one of
the top 10 most annoying things that can
happen to a human being would you not
agree that and like a popcorn kernel
being stuck in the back of your teeth
yeah so take your eyelid i did that
already okay but let's count and you
know what maybe a meditation
loving leading guided meditations i
don't know if anybody's feeling relaxed
by the things i'm saying but
your eyes closed we shall wash away the
irritation
everything will be okay when you open
your eye you will see clearly you don't
sound like a meditator you sound like a
hypnotist that's true okay how do i be a
meditator okay can i open my eye
no keep it closed
let me work on my meditations embrace
your inner melissa wood health
i don't i don't stream okay
you are beautiful stunning and smart
hum
you will get this thing out of your eye
hum
you will have a wonderful day of sight
hum bryce and stress and rising stress
and okay i'm opening mine now i can open
it
it's still there
i tried my best you can't say it's fine
i'm just going to be like twitching all
day and like
everyone on youtube well they have
bigger problems maybe we should maybe we
should stream on twitch
[Laughter]
totally
all right let's just ignore it and like
hopefully it'll go away yeah that's how
that's what usually happens whenever i
have an ailment and they do the toast i
just ignore it and i forget about it
until we wrap yeah certain ailments like
literally can't be ignored because i'm
actually like having
like a major twitch but
you ever want to gauge your own [ __ ]
eye out wow something i mean i would i
think i know what's bothering you today
it's the twitch yeah
but
you're
you're bothered
wouldn't you yeah it's like since i did
my makeup i think i like
brushed a makeup bristle into my eye
when i was doing my makeup and it never
left someone to see if there's anything
there no but i might like
let go look in the mirror really look in
the mirror and i can guide everyone
through a meditation
what do we need for this tuesday i think
a tuesday meditation to give you
the courage to get through the rest of
the week so
please with me hands up pause up
close your eyes
um it's tuesday
some say it's a better day than monday
others say it's the worst day of the
week no matter how you feel about
tuesday let's be grateful for this
opportunity
that we are alive on this tuesday
that we are toasters on this tuesday
that means we are beautiful stunning and
smart with an amazing sense of humor
unless we're hate listening to this show
in which case you're still a fan
welcome to the morning toast
okay you guys i feel good
that was really beautiful i fee i really
feel
like a meditator like
meditated you know
okay she's coming back
honestly i pulled something out it does
feel better
great so let's just now we can dive in
your eye is clear the toasters are
meditated as am i so without further
do let's get into the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
away i literally just got a new away
yesterday for my trip this weekend
gorgeous away creates thoughtful
products designed to change how you see
the world they started with the perfect
suitcase crafted with features that make
travel more seamless and now with even
the familiar even when the familiar
looks different you can count on a waze
range of essentials to solve real travel
problems whenever you take that next
trip so their suitcases have amazing
features um
no matter where you go they offer a
range of suitcases and other travel
products made of different materials
like polycarbonate aluminum durable
nylon they're built to last they have
durable exteriors that can withstand
even the roughest of baggage handlers
every suitcase comes with an interior
organization system that includes a
built-in compression pad to help you
pack more in that built-in compression
pad is perfection for clean granny
panties and they have a hidden and
removable laundry bag that separates
your dirty clothes which is perfect for
your dirty granny panties their four
wheels have 360 degree spinners that are
guaranteed for the smoothest roll even
through the most hectic airports their
combination lock is tsa approved and
honestly like if you don't have in a way
suitcase like you're just not
traveling right like why would you make
your life harder especially when
traveling is so treacherous so they also
offer 100-day trial on everything that
they make so you take the product on the
road you live with it you travel with it
get lost with it for a hundred days if
you decide it's not for you you can
return any non-personalized item for a
full refund during that period there's
no ifs ands or buts so they offer free
shippings and return shipping and
returns on any order within the
contagious us europe canada and
australia and you could start your 100
day trial and shop the entire away
lineup of travel essentials including
their best selling suitcases at
awaytravel.com toast that's
awaytravel.com
toast today's episode is also brought to
you by little spoon little spoon is a
one-stop shop for healthy easy meal time
and snack time for your baby toddler and
big kid it's all delivered right to your
door
most of the baby food and kid suit at
the grocery store is super processed and
it sits on the shelf longer than your
little one has even been alive so it's
not cool and it's not the quality
nutrition that your kids deserve little
spoon makes everything fresh and uses
absolutely nothing artificial it's just
like homemade but it's all delivered to
your door ready in seconds pop your
meals in the fridge or the freezer and
just use them when they're ready that's
easy all their recipes taste absolutely
delicious they're nutritionally balanced
and free of junk so it's helping to set
your little one up for a lifetime of
health we tried everything and it tastes
actually great jackie's babe harry has
been living on it and it's nice to like
as he gets older you're not gonna have
to transition out of it you know
the smoothies um make snack time so much
easier all their flavors are inspired by
a classic treat so you can feel good
about the organic quality ingredients
that they're eating the best part is
that the price is right with kids meal
under five dollars and baby food and
smoothie snacks under three dollars it
makes trying little spoon so easy start
the new year fresh with little spoon and
get 50 off your first order with the
code toast at checkout that's code toast
at checkout at little spoon um
off your first order check it out
check it out i just want to clarify he's
still on breast milk but little spoon is
what we're going to be using and miss
kaler loves little spoons thank you she
is a little spoon and as we've stated
it's camper tested counselor approved
our first story some controversy for kim
she may have damaged the marilyn monroe
met gala dress the historic dress once
worn by marilyn monroe that kim showed
off at the 2022 met gala appears to be
damaged from its night out according to
an observer the marilyn monroe
collection instagram account posted new
photos monday showing the bedazzled
dress which marilyn wore to sing happy
birthday mr president in 1962 to jfk but
the dress appeared to be missing a few
crystals claimed the account which added
that others seem to be hanging by a
thread
kim vowed not to make any alterations to
the dress which has been declared a
national treasure and altered herself
instead she now infamously admitted that
she lost 16 pounds in three weeks in
order to squeeze into the dress so i'm
sure a lot of people have seen the
pictures if not check it out at marilyn
monroe collection before and after with
you know some rhinestones missing there
are definitely some rhinestones missing
i have something to say hold on i just
want to look up the pictures that
marilyn monroe collection posted okay
okay because
i was looking i was reading this whole
saga
and the before picture i had heard and i
read on twitter was from 2016.
so again
i'm not sure if that's true i just
wanted people to keep that in mind okay
but the dress really shouldn't have
changed at ripley's between 2016 and
2022. yeah okay so
of course everyone is like quaking using
this as uh commentate com
using this to commentate on like the
kardashians value nothing they just want
money
um
if the dress was so fragile like i blame
ripley's like your literal job is to
conserve [ __ ] and you didn't conserve it
sorry this has nothing to do with kim if
they thought it was gonna get ripped or
that she actually really couldn't fit in
it and she would be damaging the dress
like that's on them to tell her no
yeah
yes also like
can't they just put the crystals back on
like you know don't they restore
clothing too a lot of like you know
iconic dresses that are in museums now
like the person wore and partied the
night away right also kim didn't party
the night away she got into it and then
she took it off the replica and i think
there just needs to be some restoration
now i mean
it's just like coliseum's people were p
like pissed at him for wearing this
dress before there were missing crystals
and i think that for those people this
is just like and this just goes to show
yeah especially because bob mackie who
made the dress said like you know kim
never should have worn it yeah so um
i don't know i feel like
like some diet prada posted it and like
people in the comments were like people
who like i guess love fashion like
literally sobbing like that the dress
was pulled and it's like first of all
everyone calm the [ __ ] down it's a dress
and it's not even yours so calm down and
second about like marilyn is rolling
what the [ __ ] do you know did you know
her
so like first of all i think if there's
anyone to blame it's ripley's because
it's their literal job to make sure that
this didn't happen
but i will say like when i saw footage
of kim going and trying it on and then
like putting it up her body like they
were being like really rough like the
way they were like trying to get it over
here
yes like like that's that's literally
gonna
bring
bedazzles off yes they were going like
this yeah like rouging it up her ass
because it didn't fit yeah um
i just feel like
at the end of the day and i love history
and i think you know relics
should be protected protected restored
respected
at the end of the day it's a dress
marilyn wore a lot of dresses
it can be restored yeah it's just people
want to hate on kim and like this just
proves to them that she did something
wrong and the people who were angry that
she wore it now feel vindicated right
and the people who thought it was a nice
moment in time like us are like what's
the big whoop yeah so like i just hate
these types of stories that just like
make the kardashians look bad you know
yeah because
it's so easy like everyone just jumps on
the hate train um and i just think a lot
of people like when i was reading like
comments on twitter like they take
themselves so seriously like calm the
[ __ ] down it's literally a dress that
doesn't even know what this dress was
before she wore it like right no people
are like like being so like literally
writing proverbs like
the value of a dollar and exposed in
hollywood i'm like shut the [ __ ] up like
it's so not that serious dresses like
this can be mended dresses can be mended
it's in the hands of ripley's i believe
they know what they're doing they'll get
it right um and if they didn't think if
they thought that like she might damage
it to a point of no return they wouldn't
have let her wear it yeah everyone just
needs to like chill out everyone is so
like bent out of shape when it comes to
the kardashians it's like why don't you
harvest that energy towards like
something actually important no or maybe
you know like why don't you harvest that
energy towards yourself like you know
self-care look inward look inward people
are just honestly people are so toxic
yeah and maybe this is like me yes being
kardashian kardashian apologist but like
even if it was someone else i would be
like okay it's a dress it can be fixed
calm down yeah and it's not like she
intentionally disrespected the dress
like that's
dropped it low right
she handled it with the utmost care and
respect and
so some crystals were lost along the way
like that's the job of ripley like
before kim wore this did you even one
know about this dress know where she
know where marilyn wore it knew that it
was even at ripley's no you didn't you
didn't so why do you give [ __ ] yeah it's
um
it to me it's like it can be fixed yeah
it's like aren't we not supposed to be
putting you know too much emphasis on
material items yeah
but it is history and i get like wanting
to preserve it and respect it and i
think it'll be okay like i think
everyone really like calm down i do
think it's gonna be okay you know when
you look at it from the lens of the big
bang theory it's literally irrelevant
it's really just a few crystals yeah
and it's a few crystals but it's also
like the lining towards the zipper it's
like a little pulled it's called a
sewing machine they use them all the
time on drag race project runway it'll
be fine especially if you get like the
best seamstress in the world especially
when these are like costume historians
whose job it is to restore right okay so
you know what it makes me think of this
you know what it makes you think of i
want to know if you can guess what movie
i'm thinking of head over heels holy
[ __ ] head over heels where they sit in
the museum basement and restore works of
art so if you don't know head over heels
it's an iconic 90s
starring freddie prince jr and a girl
who like really didn't get famous um and
i don't even know her name but she's
like this really cute like girl and her
job is being in art she works at the met
and she preserves old pieces of art she
restores them when they come you know to
the
to the museum for the first time if
they've been sitting out too long she
takes them downstairs gives them a nice
nice bite so yeah we can restore like a
painting from the 1500s but not a dress
from 50 years ago calm the [ __ ] down
it'll be okay yeah and even if it's not
okay which would be terrible
let's get some perspective like it's not
your dress
did you pay for it did you wear it to
prom are you going to go to ripley's and
visit it
right you're going to go to orlando
right calm down
and if you say that you were i want to
see that you've been in the past yeah
show me your ticket are you a ripley's
adult are you is that that's definitely
a thing have you ever been to a ripley's
i don't think so there's one in the city
yeah i know i get confused because i've
been to a madame tussau
so different also how do you pronounce
madame tussaud madame two stoves yeah
people say like
madame tussaud because there's a d but
like it's french they say two sods yeah
like i always hear people saying that
like when they were printing out on
social media now it's giving like madame
trudeau
now i'm confusing it justin's wifey
or is madame tussauds
yeah it's actually like such a fun place
yeah we should go i know actually i've
had like many important moments there
like i when i think of it initially i
always think as kids we went there all
the time we have like a million pictures
with the spice girls we used to go all
the time then me and ben's like third
official date we like weirdly went to
madame tussaud because there was like a
carmelo anthony
wax figure and then a couple years ago i
actually did a partnership with madame
tussau i really like stan yeah no it's
really a cute thing and the celebrities
love it too because it's such an honor
yeah i will say though one of my
favorite like tropes in pop culture is
like when someone newly famous gets a
wax figure and it looks nothing like
them and they look like twisted yeah
that's my favorite good times good times
but we should go to ripley's yeah no
i've never actually i feel like i have
been
there is there one or like a few
let me see like the the maryland dress
is in orlando
maybe there's just like one
you know
i feel like i've been honestly
there's definitely one in vegas
yeah and there's definitely one in the
city
liberties would believe it or not nyc
permanently closed cool cool but that's
just like classic new york yeah but it's
also right next to madame tussauds
that's why i'm confused yeah okay yes
yes yes i know what you're talking about
now yeah okay are you ready for our next
story yeah but like to me mata like
ripley's believe it or not was like the
tacky version of madame tusso like as a
kid i'd be like oh i would never go to
ripley's you know right but what the
[ __ ] did i know i do think that kim has
done a lot for ripley's now yeah well to
be honest when i heard that ripley's was
the owner of the dress i was like shook
because i always thought of ripley's is
like come see like pt barnes like come
see the world's biggest tooth like
i i never thought of it like as
glamorous fashion so you know what like
you would think that dress would be like
sotheby's
the met vogue owns it something but i
never would have thought ripley's in
orlando you know and look now we're
talking about ripley's and look what kim
is doing for the tourism board of
orlando
yeah boosting the economies left right
and center yeah but she's gotten like so
much flack for like wearing the stress
losing the weight damaging the dress
it's like i wonder if sure at the end of
the day if it was worth all the turmoil
i do think it was and also speaking of
losing the weight i was looking for
stories today and i saw like literally
the most
hypocritical [ __ ] it was buzzfeed and
it was like 10 male actors um
and how they dropped like tons of weight
for
certain roles to fit into like the toxic
hollywood body image it's like no one
was talking about him like that like
they were just like kim is kim is the
toxic hollywood body image it was just
beyond hypocritical got it
are you ready for our next story
lizzo releases a new version of her song
girls after backlash over ableist lyric
she said i never want to promote
derogatory language so now she's
released a new version of her single
after receiving backlash from disability
advocates for including
this word in the song's beginning lines
now where are we not i don't think
here's the thing like i never knew that
this word was in any way a slur jackie
no human being on the planet knew that
okay and now i'm scared if i say it
then someone's gonna roll this back in
like 10 years in ten years when
everybody knows this is a word we don't
use it'll be march 2018 all over again
don't say well no okay but i want you
guys to know what word we're talking
about they know what it is do you i
really i didn't know okay can i tell you
that um like a couple days ago i saw
tick tock like every now and then i'll
get hit with tic tocs that have no likes
usually it's just like once i go viral
but every now and then it's like a
random person in the middle of nowhere
and there was a person going on and on
about how ableist this lyric was and i
deadass like was cracking up and i
almost sent it to you but oh my people
have lost their minds and then over the
next last couple days it like turned
into an actual movement i literally
thought it was a joke and before i give
my opinion on this i would just like to
say under very clear terms like i am not
ableist you are not gonna [ __ ] stick
that on me i'm not [ __ ] ableist i'm
not okay i'm not don't even try don't
comment i'm not [ __ ] ableist okay
but i think this is like a little like
wild
this is
a little wild i would say and i also
think i always think it's interesting
when people decide to make a movement
out of something around a certain person
whether or not the movement is valid i
just think it's always really
interesting which person sparks that so
um do you know how many people have used
this lyric in popular music over the
last 10 years literally a million people
has anyone ever said anything about it
no well here's the thing i would have
never heard about this story aside from
the zero likes tick tock that you saw i
would have never heard about this story
if lizzo didn't change the lyric so
maybe in all of those past instances
there was a little bit of a movement
swirling but the artist didn't
acknowledge it so it never made it to
press but now it's like lizzo changed a
lyric that's news i had heard about it
before she changed it and everyone was
like what is she gonna do oh
yeah but i'm also like my head is so far
up the internet's ass right you hear
about everybody i hear about everything
so that's a good point like maybe it's
now officially becoming a thing because
she acknowledged it and i don't think
lizzo is not a bad person i don't think
liza wants anyone to listen to her music
and feel triggered so lizzo did what she
thought was right but like i just really
i'm like shook that we like reached a
new level like i didn't know there were
words
like obviously we know what words are
good and we know what words are bad
right i just didn't know there was like
a new word
yeah
and
i had no idea i also was reading some
comments because apparently like the
comments on the ins on her instagram
post announcing it were like
much a lot of people being like what but
i think they've also been deleting those
comments because it's you know adding to
the offense right but i did see some
comments that were like in
internationally in the commonwealth this
is a really bad word
oh
oh okay well that would make sense
yeah cause i had no idea it was a bad
word here and
i also want you guys to know what word
we're talking about just google it like
yeah i'm not saying it i'm not i'm not
throwing my life on the line i know i
was gonna like maybe drop a letter in
this minute and then the next letter a
minute later no it's a four-letter word
it's not worth it seriously don't
[ __ ] say it like we have too much to
lose okay okay okay
ten years for me now like well thank you
our business will be thriving
um i just didn't know this was a thing
and it's just just a lot it's a lot to
learn even though this isn't a word like
this doesn't affect me like i don't
think i've actually ever used this word
it's kind of like a lame word like who
says that there's like such better words
to describe i think what she was trying
to say yeah so i've never used this word
it's not going to like affect my life at
all have you heard the song before like
with the word like do you know the lyric
uh
i heard it on tick tock yes did you like
the beat actually it wasn't a song that
spoke to me initially so it's not like i
have to unlearn the word from the song
you know what's the chorus i don't know
oh okay i wouldn't know i don't think
the song is even out yet i think she
teased it on tick tock
with a couple lines including the one
that had the slur which was just
you know
a coincidence got it
i just think it's interesting how the
conversation's being had now like around
lizzo like is it because she's a woman
makes you think uh
no i think it's because
well what other songs are you talking
about like i literally saw a tick tock i
saw a tick tock of somebody compiling
like screenshots of a lyrics from like a
bunch of different songs
um
but are they from 2022 i think it's a
product of the time that we're in and
the fact that
you know if it was 10 years ago the
black eyed peas were saying the r word
on the radio yeah but but you know what
we don't talk about that enough the
black eyed peas were saying the r word
on the radio everyone the song was let's
get it started in huh but it started
was initially the r word and you can
just figure that out yourself um
that's not spoken about enough because i
feel like that word was already on the
outs
when
that's a crazy lyric it's [ __ ] crazy
and that that word was already on the
outs when it came out and i feel like
nobody ever talks about it and you know
a couple weeks ago snl did a skit about
the black eyed peas like they're in the
studio coming up with lyrics and i was
like oh they're gonna address it because
it's like it's like this big pop culture
thing that nobody talks about and they
literally made the most unfunny skit
about like
the black eyed peas they didn't even
address they were talking literally
about the song
but they didn't even address the fact
that the original lyrics were let's get
r and that's why snl will just never be
on appointment yeah um
i think that's a worthwhile cause
because that's actually [ __ ] ableist
that word yeah but no but it just goes
to show that at the time that they were
singing it there was not well maybe
there must have been some sort of
movement because they did have the
alternate lyric it started well
alternately
for radio because you can't use that
word on the radio
so like if you put it on itunes explicit
back in the day it would have the r word
but if you heard it on the radio it
wasn't the r word wasn't on the radio no
the r word couldn't be on the radio okay
or like everyone makes audio everyone
makes
clean versions of their song for radio
you can't be playing words with uh
curse words yeah on the radio
i thought hold on i'm looking at an
article because
the black eyed peas quietly changed the
offensive lyrics to the original let's
get it started
yeah i think that it was the r word and
then they changed it at like
down the line
the way that i remember it happening was
that they had both versions one for
radio and one for like not radio and
then they just started using the radio
version everywhere to save face
got it
okay
anyway that was [ __ ] crazy yeah well
i think at the time like it's much
crazier to think about now versus at the
time it wasn't a crazy big deal
which is how this feels like maybe in 10
years we'll like look back and be like
oh my god i can't believe she put that
word in maybe but i i remember it being
crazy
okay i don't
i do i just like know now
that it's crazy no what was that 2010
you said oh i don't know hold on when
did they release that song
let's get it started
i'm sorry
sorry i'm a clown you're frazzled
frazzled 2004. oh okay okay okay okay
so yeah maybe that was a little early i
was in like the fourth grade i feel like
maybe people were still saying that word
yeah it was released in 2003 as let's
get our word and then it took off when
it was re-released later that year it's
a much more marketable let's get it
started got it
no i mean when you watch like entourage
and it won the grammy
for best friend
in 2004 so no they won it for started
when you watch old episodes of entourage
like season one they use the r word and
the f slur like every other word
yeah and that's around the same time
yeah so i guess yeah
i don't know i i guess we'll have to see
how we feel but we have to watch this
episode in 10 years and see if this slur
took off or not yeah
okay
are you ready for our next story uh no
actually oh thank you for asking let's
do what you need to do to get ready for
our next story
today's episode the next story is
brought to you by noom
unlike other restrictive diets or
workout programs new weight uses
psychology to empower you with the
practical knowledge and skills you need
to build smarter more sustainable
long-term habits and behaviors
their psychology-based approach is
scientifically based and has proven
principles like cognitive behavioral
therapy
which helps people
better understand their relationship
with food and why they eat the way that
they do they understand that weight loss
journey is difficult and it's filled
with ups and downs ain't that the truth
but that's why they believe it's about
progress not perfection because
everybody's journey is different i would
say i'm in progress stage no not perfect
and tell me about how noom is helping
you with that noom is my my buddy in in
this journey of mine i love their um
database of their food database where i
can program in everything that i've
eaten a day because sometimes you know i
feel like i'm doing good and then i'm
not seeing the results that i want and
i'm like where did i go wrong noom and
they're like girl you're eating a lot
or like this thing that you're eating
doesn't have the proper you know
nutritional value for the calories spent
and it's really very informative and it
leaves you knowing what you're doing
wrong and how you can fix it to achieve
the goals that you want to achieve and
noom doesn't put pressure on you you
know they're just like we're here if you
need us do your thing they make it easy
to start on your weight loss journey and
stay on track their personalized lessons
help you gain confidence with practical
knowledge you can employ right away with
one-on-one coaching you'll always have
guidance and support on your journey
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results and sign up
for your trial at noom.com
toast that's n o o m dot com slash toast
thank you claudia yeah our next story
some bittersweet news morgan stewart
came back to daily pop yesterday just to
announce that she's leaving daily pumps
morgan stewart made her highly
anticipated return to daily pop
yesterday and is saying goodbye to the
show though she is returning to nightly
pop back from maternity leave the
longtime host reunited with her fellow e
personalities justin sylvester and
lonnie love on june 13th show bringing
with her some bittersweet news she said
today is unfortunately going to be my
last official day on daily pop it was a
very hard decision but this time i was
pregnant for so long i want to enjoy the
mornings with my babies while they're
still babies totally understandable
respect your decision like respect
working moms i do have a lot of thoughts
on this okay my first thought is that i
actually think this is the best thing
for lonnie love because the reel just
got cancelled and she was always like in
and out of e but now i feel like she
literally used to do a morning show and
now hopefully she'll take morgan's spot
permanently yeah will she i haven't
watched a lot of daily pop since morgan
went on maternity leave but every time i
would watch like lonnie is always there
so hopefully she just gets that second
chair right permanently now it's just
like a rotating door because they never
fully
replaced carissa
um and i think we can all agree like
carissa morgan and justin like were the
best
threesome factor um and so i'm glad
morgan still eddie even though nightly
pop is like not my favorite show um by
any means and i think morgan's talents
are much better
utilized at daily pop um but i just
think this is a problem e has in general
like
e is consistently just like doing the
least like of all time they have such a
stars like the way that they haven't
really utilized morgan and justin
to the best of their abilities is such a
mistake because they're such stark
quality people and they're both going to
go on to do huge things and i do think
in a few years that will have nothing to
do with e anymore um and e is just like
constantly like just not doing not doing
what they need what needs to be done
they should be so grateful for justin
and morgan and i feel like they give
them the bare minimum
and e is just becoming more relevant
like as the days go by yeah i think with
you know the loss of e news and then the
kardashians and then uh the nikki glazer
show which their whole campaign was like
i'm replacing the kardashians it was
like supposed to be funny but it just
came off like really bitter oh though
she's like
like the whole ad campaign
theme was like replacing five brunettes
with one blonde it was just like not
funny at all and it was just like
it's like awkward like no you actually
did lose a kardashian so that was like
literally a whole thing so like
you really shouldn't be talking about it
yeah or like
i don't the two things aren't the same
and i feel like everyone knew they were
losing the kardashians they should have
come out with a show like literally the
same day that kardashian's hulu dropped
that was like we found this new family
the scala sisters
literally here is an amazing show that
is going to be our new kardashians so i
did i do think they tried to do that
with the bradshaw bunch terry no but
they launched bradshaw bunch like two to
three years ago they should have
launched a new show that day and been
like we are the star makers and here's
your next family sister scala the scala
sisters that's such a good call like
should i expose myself okay uh last
night i literally spent four hours like
on a scala family rabbit hole um
and i always knew like rach was rage
like i feel like we've been rach girlies
now for like what over a year over a
year or two last christmas and i feel
like i've been you know better off
because i haven't known her yeah um sort
of known her um and honestly never
really delved into the whole family and
i didn't even realize the similarities
between our family and theirs four
sisters one younger one not married very
connected to their faith like i'm
literally obsessed no literally obsessed
and the way i've been obviously when we
discovered rachel was like
a whole new world it was a whole new
world and we were really obsessed with
like her style and her house and really
rage things yeah but over the last few
months i've really been
delving into the rest of the sisters and
the family like emily and rache and
emily really remind me of me and you no
sami because they like work together and
they're both like business women in the
influencer space
and
when you when they're together like
their stories are so funny and i'm just
loving and amy um she's this is she's
the snitch i think she like babysits for
rachel's yes yes and it's just so cute i
mean goals like snitch would never come
help me never um and here are words and
then meg just had a baby when i had a
baby here are words like i just truly
never thought would come out of my mouth
but like
i never in my life have i like really
wavered in my faith but like the
scholars make me want to convert like
dead ass like
because like i just want to you know
yeah should i become mormon i think it
would suit you i don't really like
drinking oh
and what how do they feel about
vaping oh that's that's a really really
good call um okay maybe the mormon faith
is not for me maybe i could start like
you know jewish community in utah and
like we are allies with mormons lisa
barlow literally oh my god i forgot to
tell you something
okay um i watched a documentary called
um
pray and obey keep sweet pray and obey
and it is about flds the fundamentalists
of the latter day saints church and i
just want to say like i hate religious
documentaries because i feel like they
really um
like people just associate like the
extreme groups with like
like all mormons are like that you know
and they're [ __ ] not so i just wanted
to say that like flds is not a lds no an
lds doesn't [ __ ] claim these freaks
from flds like they were kicked out like
a while ago because over 100 years ago
the mormon lds church
disallowed uh polygamy and these flds's
were like [ __ ] no so they got together
and started this community and it's and
it turned out like
it went on forever and it still goes on
and it's so toxic so many terrible
things happen but for a while like lds
was like we do not [ __ ] with these
freaks like do not but it was really
interesting i won't go into the whole
thing but if you enjoy documentaries
like that i encourage you to watch it
they had a woman talking who um was it
rage no
no
who had left
who had left him was like talking about
her experience and
her name last name was barlow
and barlow is
lisa's husband's last name and lisa is a
convert but her husband's not oh
i just found that that interesting you
know i don't think there's anything
there but i was like is she related to
lisa
interesting yeah oh okay
okay good documentary really upsetting
like uh you know documentaries at the
end that gave him no resolve like yeah
we all know this is going on and it
still happens right like okay don't make
a documentary until it's over because
now you're just keeping me up at night
well maybe the documentary will create
some momentum
that could help end something yeah like
telecom
right right that's true that's true
black fish was that is that what's
called
such a good
such a good documentary that one really
actually changed my life yeah
anyways morgan stewart's leaving daily
oh right and how did we
that was one of our like crazier
tangents yeah and
i'm sad i love daily pop i love morgan
and justin's dynamic and i
yes we can see her on nightly pop but it
isn't the same but maybe because and i
think for a while when she was doing
like daily pop nightly have necessary
illness every single day it's hard to
find different things to talk about
maybe nightly pop will turn a little
more into daily pop now that she doesn't
have to give that deli pop energy to
daily pop yeah nightly pop juice is so
scripted and it gives me like the soup
vibes which was
a good vibe when the soup was airing it
just feels kind of dated now
um
and it just doesn't feel like super
irrelevant
yeah and i don't know i just think
morgan's talents are better suited on
deli pack but i understand not wanting
wanting to be with your kids in in the
morning and i totally respect that yeah
i just don't know like what this means
for e as a whole i feel like daily pop
was so good for so long and then carissa
leaving like really just started this
like trail of uncertainty yeah well she
did say and i'm sure we'll see her like
every time justin's off like morgan will
come in and she'll
be here and there but as a permanent
co-host she is no longer so it's really
just justin right now and they must find
him and he puts the whole show on his
back and he knows how yeah
or morgan could do like afternoon pop
and
make it more like daily pop and then she
could be in the with her kids in the
morning but then that's like three shows
but then like i'm just saying because
you're not here for nightly pops no i'm
just trying to compromise um also she
announced that her husband got a
vasectomy yes which is so crazy yeah i
mean vasectomies like actually aren't
crazy because you can literally reverse
them um
so i love that for her like she's like
she just did the pandemic right like she
started the pandemic a girl with a
boyfriend she's ending the pandemic like
a girl with a family you know
yeah and like a a great job so
overwhelming that she has to take a step
back you know yeah
some things are just not fair
no it was nice to see her back on popeye
watch this morning and
but it was also bittersweet because they
were like talking about amber heard they
were being so funny oh were they and
they're really so real considering
they're like on television right you
have to be like you know you have to see
exactly but they still keep it real and
i will miss that i will miss that too
but happy for her it was nice to see her
again yeah
our next story some more adorable news
blue ivy is adorably embarrassed by
jay-z's hug and kiss at the nba finals
people are co-waking over the pictures
of blue ivy and jay-z from the
basketball game yes cause the pictures
are so sweet so cute and blue's all
grown up blue is a grown-ass woman like
yeah it's it's shocking i mean i guess
she's 10.
that's grown and maybe she just like
she's dressed up really nice 10 is not
grown i i know that we're like saying
like she's like
she has grown more since we last saw her
but 10 is not grown maybe then like i
think why people are quaking is because
like she's all done up and it's just
you know it's giving suri crews like i
feel like when we were younger like we
all watched sorry crews get older and
honestly like a weird part of getting
older is watching celebrities kids grow
up into like full-blown adults mason
disick
so um this is just that moment and we
don't see a lot of blue she doesn't have
like an instagram right beyonce is not
always taking pictures of her when you
see someone every day whether it's a
celebrity kid or someone you know you
don't notice their growth right but when
you see someone like a few years later
yeah it's shocking really starting to
look like beyonce like she's really
beautiful she's wearing earrings like
she was giving like the people what they
needed yeah i saw side by side of her
and like a young beyonce and they look
so similar well when she was younger a
lot of people like didn't even see the
beyonce she looked so much like jay-z
and now she's really starting to look
like her mom as little girls always look
like their dads that's what i realized
that's true and then i realized that
boys look like they're moms it's true
and then i saw recently that the
firstborn girl
always looks like the dad and the
firstborn boy always looks like the mom
i don't know if it means like second
third and fourth boys and girls like the
genders are like that but that's what
i've in my own life that's what i've
seen yeah no i definitely think like
there's not like a formula for it it's
just like genetics you know no
it's like that's really what i've seen
like michaela is zak shapiro
yeah sometimes it's hard to tell them
apart so true you don't know who you're
talking to that's so true and people
have said i look like haroldson you do
you and harry are like literally twins
i actually sent you sent such gorgeous
pictures of harry today into our family
chat i sent them to my friend chat and
they were like literally jogging yeah
what's good like jackie looks so young
what's crazy though is i can't see it
really that makes sense i i didn't know
that because i can see other people so
easily yeah of course i think that's
normal i don't think like whenever i
mean it didn't happen and i asked olivia
i was like did shapiro see that michaela
looks like him because to me they're
identical and she said no yeah like it
didn't happen to us growing up but like
when people would go up to sisters and
be like oh man you guys look so much
alike you were like really it didn't
happen to us because we looked nothing
alike but yes but you really can't tell
who you look like it's like you're in
your own body yes except every once in a
while i'll see a picture of like margot
and i think it's me yeah or i'll see a
picture of you and i'm like
i'll think it's me or i'll see you like
i remember watching your special your
first special
and
in so many angles you look like margot i
got that a lot available to stream um on
amazon prime for free just grace queen
yes i got that a lot that am i special
every time someone paused they came back
and literally thought it was margo is
there anything nicer they could say
no
actually they could say i look like
gisele but you know i have to be
realistic yeah yeah yeah you're short
right and fat and ugly
it is like low-key weird though like how
little we look like you know yeah like
this that's why this show is confusing
because when you get the four sisters
together like maybe you could see it
it's somewhat cohesive yes but you and i
look the least alike out of all four i
look a lot like olivia yes
you look like margot i look like
margaret i look like olivia yes you and
i look the least alike and margo and
olivia yeah it's so
true who are they what are those
these are clothes
what are those
our fifth and final story is about a
ship i didn't even know that i had that
has already sunk
oh no that's so sad oh my god also i
read hook line and sinker the um sequel
to
it happened one summer you can skip it i
was planning on it because that girl
collects records and that's not a
personality trait no and like the whole
book was like music and it was giving
like pick me energy like
oh i need to listen to a song should i
listen to the national like
stop listen to taylor swift
um okay the fifth and final story is
brought to you by honey imagine you're
shopping on one of your favorite
websites and when you check out the
honey button we'll just drop down and
all you do is click apply coupons wait a
few seconds as honey searches for
coupons it can find for that site and
once they find it you'll watch the price
drop like literally so easy
literally if you don't have honey the
toasters told us about honey like five
years ago and it's the best thing that
ever happened to me just got a new
computer one of the first things i did
download google chrome and then download
um
honey so it's a browser extension when
you use our link it's totally free to
download and every time you're shopping
online whether it's for makeup clothing
electronics food whatever it is
literally this little button will pop up
and be like hey [ __ ] you want to save
some money and you click apply coupons
and most of the time it'll find
a coupon for you like that you don't
like go searching like coupon for
revolve like right they'll just find it
for you it's so easy it's free to
download when you use our link so like
literally what are you doing what are
you doing i've used it on everything i
have to tell you about it get your
[ __ ] ass up and use honey i was
shopping for baby clothes recently and i
was doing like a big order from multiple
sites and i had just gotten a computer
and i was like why do these cards look
so expensive where's honey i saved like
almost 100 across all sites i'm about to
change your life ready do you know you
can now add honey to your phone
your iphone enable it on safari and you
can find it and you can find savings on
the go
it's over it's game over so if you don't
already have honey you're straight up
missing out it's literally free installs
in a few seconds and by getting it
you're doing yourself a solid we'd never
recommend something we don't use so get
honey for free at joinhoney.com
toast that's join honey dot com slash
toast
are you ready for our fifth and final
story if it's the final story
scholar sisters coming to you next fall
on e
and that's a magic number
gorgeous sorry if you had a sleeping
baby like genuinely really sorry because
we didn't even give you a warning you
didn't know that was coming yeah our
fifth and final story the ship that has
sunk you know jason mamoa and aza
gonzalez break up after months of dating
saying they're very different people
like months
where were we
no i don't agree i remember hearing like
spotted together and then never no
follow-up so i was like oh it's just
like paparazzi like drama i never even
heard spotted together seeing their
pictures side by side right now it's
like
my ships are quaking no i know they're
rumbling i'm sorry isa gonzalez like
literally has the best taste in men and
not only does she have the best taste in
men she has like access to them too
because like it's easy to like have good
taste in jason mama but like good luck
making it happen right she yeah exactly
i wouldn't be doing any differently if i
were her except like why didn't this
work right but she's actually like let's
go through she was dating josh dumel for
a little while post fergie which was so
iconic she was spotted with tim timothy
chalamet which i honestly wasn't my
favorite oh no no i'm not i'm not a
timothy chalamet really and i'm not
gonna get into it um
[Applause]
that was how i first found out who she
was yeah because like post smiley he was
with this like gorgeous model
and it was ace gonzalez she has great a
great relationship track history track
record she does and i just want to put
this out there again now that we're
talking about her like she must play
evelyn hugo and the seven husbands of
evelyn hugo it's true like she must do
you see they're making it happen one
summer into a movie i did yeah who would
you want to see for it um i like don't
remember the book but all i remember is
like piper being like so sickening and
cool
um and like la and like effortlessly
beautiful and like
on like i don't think now but like when
is do you ever like think of someone in
a book as like a celebrity but like from
10 years ago how they looked
perhaps who are you thinking hyper power
bow like from cheaper by the dozen
because her name was piper yes but also
like the way that they described her
looks like she really looked like and i
actually think of piper powerball for a
lot of the books that i read oh
interesting well everybody's saying
because the character is
uh
alexis rose
no she comes from the city no no small
town with like all of her fashion but
she's a heart of gold and she's gorgeous
you know but it's it's alexis rose
character it's not
the actor no no but the character is
alexis rose yeah but i don't think that
what's her name annie i don't think that
annie murphy right yeah would be good no
no like then it would just be alexis
rose like piper's her own person yeah
it it takes some thinking but um also we
are getting so much content from the
summer i turn to pretty like it's all
over tick tock like i'm so excited yet
no but like we're getting like two
minute trailers oh yeah
anyways the source tells people that
aiza and jason have split after people
confirmed last month that they were
dating where was my notification the
insider says you don't have your people
notifications on no i don't because i
don't want to hear about the pioneers
woman's breaking news recipe honestly i
feel like you would want to know that
actually it's true no they do really
abuse the privilege like
it's
they abuse it um a second source told
people in may that they were exclusive
and had been seeing each other since
february after meeting through work and
mutual connections and just realizing
like that they're every different people
and that they're perfect for each other
but i guess like that's the thing about
chemistry everything could be right on
paper and you know in pictures
but maybe they had nothing to talk about
yeah no it's entirely possible maybe
convo was strained but you know what
like does anyone else like still reserve
like a corner of their heart for like
the possibility of jason mamoa and
amelia clark i actually don't i think
about them often like whenever they run
into each other which is very randomly
like they have the most sweet embraces
they do but it's just like so silly at
this point that i'm i'm not seeing
sparks flying who do we set chasing mimo
up with next asa gonzalez try again just
imagine what it's like together just
imagine what it's like to be like
engulfed in a hug from jason mamawa
it's
like it happened one summer the charging
station
literally
literally no that's not it happened one
summer yeah it is
oh
no sorry i get so confused between it
happened one summer and the summer i
turned pretty all these books that have
like literally the same exact plot take
place at like different beaches but have
the same names like the summer i loved
the summer i lost like
it's so [ __ ] confusing yeah
um
this is sad but you know what we now
have two extremely good looking eligible
people back on the market um and that's
exciting yeah we need to keep a list of
like the people who are always thinking
to set people up with matt hardy matt
harvey scott gonzalez no i'm going to
start the list so we can always go back
to it so when we're thinking about like
who should chloe kardashian be with
jason momoa oh okay so khloe kardashian
jason mamoa is
khloe kardashian who recently broke up
gonzalez oh all those young hollywood
people but they're not single i know but
like did anyone break out um vanessa
hudgins but i do think she's seeing
someone
let's say go to news jason mama
comment below with all the people that
we're talking about who are pj rod is
single no no no i said p john okay and
who we are always trying to set up thank
you selena gomez
is she single yeah we never talk about
her dating life oh and chris evans yeah
chris evans and asa gonzalez
michael b jordan and lori harvey oh
that's the most recent very good that
literally just came up on my google
laurie harvey and jason mamoa
lori harvey and chris evans lori
harvey's really young like really yeah
okay let's just keep that in mind okay
because we're not gonna make any age
inappropriate no it couldn't be us yeah
could and be us um
that's really all i'm seeing on google i
literally searched breakup oh trevor
noah and mickey kelly
trevor noah and khloe kardashian
ninka kelly and jason mama
oh my god minka kelly and jason momoa is
literally the best couple of all time if
any of those pr people who like set up
people in relationships for press but
then sometimes the relationships like
actually turn out to be otp are
listening to the show please send minka
kelly and jason mamoa on a date yeah
that's like honestly perhaps one of the
best looking couples of all time
okay okay i love that we're in a really
good place yeah we have to keep the list
like but other people you guys remember
when we say these things like when we're
talking about eligible what about chloe
and jason momoa like
i just don't see it honestly even though
like he is extremely family oriented i
just feel like they're so different and
honestly i think also physically i don't
think jason mama would be chloe's type
also what's going on with shailene
woodley and aaron rodgers it's beyond
confusing i do believe they're broken up
now like it was yes they're broken up no
they're not but now i think they are and
then people stopped caring okay
okay so let's leave it at that
and we'll come back to it um okay so
that was our show
that was our show oh we'll talk about
the rest of the week wednesday tomorrow
we are here in studio and then tomorrow
night is of course our very first
episode of breaking bread our spotify
live show so make sure to download the
spotify live app and follow us breaking
red um thursday's episode is podcast
only we are both traveling you're going
to dallas for your meet and greet which
is on saturday all the information is on
the sports instagram and i'm going to
canada so thursday's episode will be
dropped early in the morning podcast
only you're going to be madame trudeau
oh literally
literally
friday no show
friday no show monday no show no show
tuesday
abandoned claudia extravaganza very fun
because jackie will still be in dallas
but then she will return and then we're
back to the regular [ __ ] next week on
wednesday so now you know now you know
because that's mike's super short show
except we don't do a super short show no
we do a very very long show very
reluctant nice and long thank you guys
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennium morning show where
we deliver the five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
radio cast box all the places so
wherever we listen to the podcast find
us morning shows leave a five star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are oh the comment that really
um like got to me about our youtube was
like well if you don't get this fixed
you're never gonna get your plaque like
wow hit me where it hurts
people are evil evil like we share we
open up we're vulnerable and then they
use it against us yeah like and we're
having a glitch like you think this is
what we want we get all glammed up i got
a spray tan to come to the studio that's
for a video you can't even see how do
you think that makes us feel no it's so
hurtful so like just know like like
we're putting on a brave face but we're
hurting we are in pain
thank you so much have a great day we'll
see you tomorrow for hump day
bye